what I want to show you in this video is
what could be described as I guess a
trick for finding binomial expansions
especially binomial expansions where the
exponent is fairly large but what I want
you to do after this video is think
about how this connects to the binomial
theorem and how it connects to Pascal's
triangle so now let me show you the
trick so I'm going to take X plus y to
the seventh power that's going to have
eight terms how do I know that well X
plus y to the first power has two terms
it's a binomial X plus y squared has
three terms X plus y to the third power
has four terms so this is going to have
eight terms so let me just create little
buckets for each of the terms so this is
the bucket these aren't the coefficients
these are just the buckets first term
second term third term fourth term fifth
term sixth term seventh term and eighth
term now let's write out the actual
let's write out the actual X's and Y so
the first term we're going to start with
X to the seventh power
then each consent each each term after
that our degree or our power on the X
goes down by one so you go X to the
sixth X to the fifth X to the fourth X
to the third x squared X to the first we
could just write that as X there's going
to be X to the 0 which is just going to
be 1 and now let's think about why this
is going to start out y to the 0 which
is just 1 so I'm not going to write it
then it's going to be Y to the first
power y squared Y to the third power Y
to the fourth power Y to the fifth power
Y to the sixth power and then Y to the
seventh power you can verify you got it
right because for each term the
exponents should add up to 7 you see
that even here this is X to the first
times y to the sixth those add up to be
seven now let's get to the interesting
part which is actually calculating the
coefficient and the algorithm is for
each term right over here so let's just
start we know the coefficient right over
here is going to be one and actually let
me write that down the coefficient over
here is going to be one
for each term the coefficient right over
here let me the coefficient I'm going to
try to color code it so we can see it
the coefficient is going to be the
exponent of the previous term so the
exponent of the previous term in this
case is the 7 the exponent of the
previous term times the coefficient of
the previous term times the coefficient
of the previous term divided by divided
by which term that actually was so
divided by the term so that was the
first term so now the coefficient on the
second term is 7 times 1 divided by 7
which is going to be equal to which is
going to be equal to 7 which is going to
be equal to 7 now what about this one
well we use the exact same process the
exact same process it is going to be it
is going to be the exponent on the X
term I guess you could say the hot the
the the exponent on X I guess we could
go with the exponent on the X which is 6
times the coefficient of the previous
term so times 7 so we're taking the hot
this the X the X power times the
coefficient of the previous term so
times 7 so the X part of the previous
term times the coefficient of the
previous term divided by the actual I
guess you could say index of the
previous term so divided by 2 so what is
that going to be so this is equivalent
to 3 times 7 so this is going to be
equal to 21 and now let's go to this
term exact same idea go to the previous
term
what's our exponent on X it is 5 let's
multiply it times the coefficient so
let's multiply it times 21 and then
let's divide it by which term that is so
that was the third term the third term
and so this is going to be let's see 5
times 21 over 3 7 so this is going to be
35 5 times 7 and we can keep going or we
can recognize that there's a symmetry
here if this is 1 then the last term
is also going to be one if this is 7
this is 7 then the second is the second
term of 7 then the second to last term
is 7 if this term is 20 with the third
term is 21 then the third term to the
last is 21 and then if the fourth term
is 35 then the fourth from the last is
35 and just like that we have figured
out the expansion of X plus y X plus y
to the seventh power
pretty neat in my mind